and then the reality is you have these
things now we've never lived in this
paradigm for a while we're now seeing
what it's like to fully live
digital
like what it feels like yeah to have all
our emotions
tied to this thing in our hands yeah
yeah it's metaverse it's coming it's one
foot
we've got one foot in yeah yeah i don't
think the metaverse is that far away in
terms of how most people live our their
lives especially
and i don't even like are you familiar
with the metaverse are you like kind of
to a degree i'm not an expert but i've
poked around i i you know i i
i think it's it's you know we're on a
three
to five year timeline before you'll
start seeing a lot of that [ __ ] me but
like
i think a lot of people are going this
is ready player one like i just put on
my goggles
and i just exist in this world and i
walk around in this world etc but my
understanding is that's not exactly what
the metaverse is not yet but you think
eventually it will be could be
might be it's hard to predict what it
would actually look like yeah it's more
just like what i will say is that people
seem
more and more
kids are digitally native yeah meaning
they're girlfriends boyfriends close
friends first meaningful experiences
things they care about things they'll
buy for clout way they flex communities
they join cultures trends yeah all are
digital nfts nfc it's all digital kids
young kids digitally native
um now some of them you know obviously
as you get older some of that changes
but does it you know yeah i think a lot
of it is kind of a permanent new
fixture in the way that people
you know operate as human beings is that
we can't pull out of this
that's the crazy thing about technology
you can't get out
you can't opt out
you will have a hard life
you can't not be you know you have to
have these things you have to be on
these services these platforms you can't
just go
hey [ __ ] that i'm out yeah it's like
because then you're a freak food
addiction right
you can't just you have to learn how to
manage yeah so at the end of the day
it's like a weird
thing because you can't you could you
could spend less time on it our buddy uh
ben oyeda you might have met ben
actually uh had an interesting theory
about like using your phone and
all these digital communities like he
thinks we'll look at social media in the
same way that we look at food
like where there's a warning on it and
it's like this has this many calories
right isn't good for you right you
should limit the amount of this
but it's going to go in there anyway no
initially with mcdonald's and [ __ ] we
were younger there was no [ __ ]
calories on anything right right it was
just
in general with cigarettes that was the
first thing where it started yeah no i'm
just saying that's again there was no
surgeon general and see it was just like
i guess we can consume this if it's
there we should be able to eat right
smoke lucky strike who gives a [ __ ] yeah
jesus man
it's what it is you know yeah
well what can we be excited about what
what can we be excited about they got
gelane
yeah i mean who cares a lot of kids lost
jobs let me ask you a question
the lane thing i find is interesting
because like
the more i thought about the epstein and
and galen stuff i'm like
are both sides using the kids in the
same way
yeah right right exactly yeah they don't
care either the other side doesn't
really give a [ __ ] it's like it's like
they're using the kids to get
incriminating [ __ ] on people they hate
and then the people that you have
clinton
right and the only the only ones who
like those kids are the ones that suffer
yeah everybody's using the kids right to
punish the people they don't like that's
right right so i'm just like
i don't know because i started thinking
eat and i've done so many [ __ ] rants
and talks about them on the podcast and
i'm like so i should know who these kids
are if i care so much about them yeah i
know one i can name one of them one
person
virginia good friend is one person
are we just using the [ __ ] girls dude
yeah yeah yeah what are we gonna do for
them
yeah you use them in a much less gross
way you know i mean yeah we are but i
guess what i'm saying is like ultimately
there are means to an end too yeah the
good news i think yeah what do you say
no that's like everything that's like
the uyghurs like do you care about the
uyghurs or do you just care about
punishing china that's what that one
indian guy was trying to tell you
everybody [ __ ] all over the indian dude
and it was their opportunity to [ __ ] all
over a rich guy yeah which is hilarious
you have all these bush era architects
of the mideast torture policy talk about
the uyghurs these are people that
literally
helped invent underground torture
prisons to torture muslims many of them
innocent of any crime yeah and they
created that program and now they're
talking about the uyghur i mean
i mean you're like what yeah yeah but
what the good news is yeah but and the
the the good things on the horizon i
think yes
the positive things on the horizon is
that the end will be swift
[Applause]
you